il a choisi d'organiser une seule
réunion publique pour cette campagne le
maire sortant de villes pro stéphane
mirambeau brigue un troisième mandat
avec une liste sans étiquette ensemble
allons plus loin
objectif de cette réunion parler des
sujets structurants du programme le
développement d'un véritable lieu de vie
au niveau du village avec l'arrivée
enfin de nouveaux commerces car on va
pouvoir créer des places de
stationnement un parc des services
publics dans le projet de central park
qui a sur lequel saint quentin avait
travaillé il ya également la
construction d'un groupe élémentaire à
côté de l'école maternelle duval joyeux
et la dernière chose si on va
redynamiser le centre ville on va bâtir
un projet avec deux grandes halles qui
va permettre à la fois de répondre aux
besoins de 2d des commerçants du marché
qui veulent être protégé un programme
qui fait suite à ce qui a été entrepris
depuis 2008
autre thème abordé la santé ou encore la
lutte contre les incivilités des idées
proposées par ses colistiers tant
qu'infirmière en fait je vous dire
clairement c'est effectivement le
central park avec notamment la maison
médicale
mon projet et à soutenir c'est surtout
la pluridisciplinarité que je
souhaiterais intégré dans cette dans ce
projet là bas moi c'est la force d'un
stand avant l'intervention en option
parce que toutes les incivilités se
passe la nuit et ça serait bien que
cette fois c'est soit créée afin de
résoudre toutes ces imbécilités pour le
bien d'une troisième des projets qui
seront développés avec une priorité on
ne peut absolument pas prendre le risque
de fragiliser un budget qu'on a mis 12
ans à stabiliser et à construire
c'est la priorité numéro un lors des
dernières élections en 2014 il n'y avait
que deux candidats stéphanie rambo avait
été élu dès le premier tour pour ce
scrutin en 2000 vingt cinq listes sont
en lice à villepreux